here with the full report Fox News
contributor our friend our 2020
correspondent on the ground Lawrence
Jones
I call him LJ and we missed you I miss
having you on the show when you we're
wait a little bit now you're back out
we're glad to have you back on the road
thank you sir good evening the des fun
please move might be the latest social
media hashtag but a new Yahoo News
YouGov poll finds that only 16% of
Americans want to defund the police and
65% of Americans opposed it
I talked with New Yorkers today and this
is what they had to say what all the
issues is going on some people have said
we should defund the police department
should we get rid of the police
department I don't think we should get
rid of it
I just think obviously you should get
out the ones that are not perfect or you
know bad if a couple of bad cop did
something bad destructive why should we
get rid of the whole police support so
we should keep the police department i
defund the police department keep and
why should we keep the police department
thought they need to protect us I think
more funding should be allocated to
preparing and prepping the officers
that's in training
to deal with the social issues and the
communities that they work in should we
defund the police department which is
just improve the police department if
you want truth it improves the police
department do away with what was that
called a chokehold so called a chokehold
I agree with you yes with all the
attention that's been going on right now
in the city we need to try to find
solutions to defuse it and also show the
people that okay the police are here
we're not your enemy we're here to help
you and to serve you Shawn as you can
see most people that I spoke with didn't
want to defund the police but they do
think certain reforms need to take place
back to you son all right so Lawrence
I'm we've been together and you've met
my my martial arts instructor let's say
right you know what I'm talking about
and like I'll give you if we have more
training
example if you take your hand you point
your your paw me a hand at your fist and
you just remember George Floyd that was
in handcuff if you just put a little
pressure on the wrist out people mmm
simple things they don't know this we
can treat them to learn these things
son you should host these conferences
across the country I bet you can teach
them you watch me in action all right
Lawrence take the damn be back